this morning we are learning more about
a new discovery in one of the world's
most ancient structures scientists say
that they have found a mysterious
chamber hidden deep inside Egypt's Great
Pyramid of Giza the cavity is the first
larger inner structure discovered inside
the pyramid since the 19th century
Jonathan Vigliotti is in London's Petrie
Museum of Egyptian archaeology with what
researchers think it might be Jonathan
good morning good morning
Egyptian culture has mesmerized
researchers like those here at London's
Petrie Museum for centuries scientists
spent two years using new technology to
see through the pyramid it's still
unclear what's inside the chamber but
the dream scenario would be finding
artifacts like these new clues into our
ancient past Egypt's Great Pyramid has
been shrouded in mystery for hundreds of
years now with the help of modern
science a breakthrough discovery the
hidden chamber stretches around 100 feet
about the same size as the Statue of
Liberty it was discovered just above the
Grand Gallery a corridor that leads to
the burial chamber of pharaoh Khufu for
whom the pyramid was built only for the
moment talking about the void Metis ty
UB is part of the international team of
researchers who made the discovery at
the moment it's still unclear what
exactly this void is maybe could be a
second Grand Gallery or if it's
horizontal
a big tunnel using a technique called
new ography researchers planted special
plates inside and around the pyramid
that recognized subatomic particles
passing through the rock revealing what
is stone and what is empty space this
kind of cat-scan for rock allows them to
look deep inside the 45 hundred-year-old
structure without drilling holes for
several years archaeology and looking at
this kind of monument was a kind of
destructive approach and now we
demonstrated that we can scan and look
behind the stone some experts have
suggested the pyramids Architects
designed the space to help maintain
structural integrity regardless of its
purpose discoveries like this may help
re-energize Egypt's crumbling tourism
industry this is absolutely an important
part of the Egyptian economy fourteen
point seven million tourists visited
Egypt in 2010 but
the country was hit hard by a 2011
uprising and the bombing of a passenger
plane in 2015
visitors to the country dropped to 5.4
million people last year there was you
know optimism among Egyptian officials
that discoveries like these would would
spawn interest
researchers say currently there are no
plans to drill into the cavity but they
are developing a tiny flying robot which
one day might be sent in to explore
what's inside Nora I want to see that
what's inside thank you so much Jonathan
Vigliotti in London they want to go